The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, so
today is the last of our guest
lectures before we
go into, what else?
Sorry.
Not the last day.
This is Monday, right?
AUDIENCE: It's Monday.
PROFESSOR: I'm already
feeling the crunch.
So we've got-- this is the
last week of guest lectures.
Today, we've got Michael
Carrier and Jenna
Hostein talking to us about the
business of Indie development.
They are representatives
from PD Game Collective.
That happens-- they are a
group of people who make games
together over in Intrepid Labs?
And that's over which
[INAUDIBLE] building?
AUDIENCE: The American
Fine Building.
PROFESSOR: The
American Fine Building.
They'll talk more about that.
They often have open
lunch days and things
like that for students to come.
So I'm sure they'll talk a
little bit about that as well.
They will also be available
after the guest lecture.
If you want them
to play your game
and get some
feedback on your game
if your game is ready
to get more feedback,
they can do that.
It's again entirely optional.
If you have a
build-- hopefully you
do-- I'll allow you to
play briefly and get
some feedback from them.
That's it.
So I'm going to hand
the stage over to them.
JENNA HOSTEIN: Is
my audio working?
We're good?
All right.
Hello.
My name is Jenna Hostein.
I'm the founder of
Little World Interactive,
and I'm a part of the Indie
Game Collective, as Rick said.
We're about six or
seven blocks north,
so we'd love to see you
guys either in the evenings,
or we do Friday
lunch get-togethers.
Michael can fill you in on that.
He is more familiar with
the details than I am.
But I am here to
talk to you today
about the business
of Indie development.
If you're an Indie
developer, you
can't get away from business.
When I first started, I--
I am a designer by trade
and a developer by necessity,
and a business person dragged
kicking and screaming into it.
It was really something
I was interested in.
It remains something that I'm
not super passionate about,
but it's absolutely crucial
to have any level of success.
So I'm going to talk to
you a little bit about what
the past couple
years have been like.
So first, let's talk about
the realities of time
as an Indie developer.
When I worked at
a larger studio,
I used to daydream about
what it would be like to work
as an Indie developer.
In those dreams,
it was me by myself
sitting at my desk just
working, and that, to me,
was like this beautiful,
glorious manna from heaven.
I just wanted to sit
and work on my game.
So this was, naively,
my expectation
going into Indie
game development--
that this was going to my life.
I actually found out,
that was not the truth.
So there are events all of
the time in the game world.
There's PAX east, PAX south,
PAX prime, PAX Australia.
GEC, Indie K, Games for Change.
I could probably list
five or ten more events
off the top of my head.
It's absolutely crucial
that you attend these
both as an attendee
just to network
and to exhibit your game.
For example, PAX
prime this year,
it took probably two,
three, maybe even four weeks
full time prepping for
that, attending that,
and then coming down
from that and tying up
all the loose ends.
So do not underestimate
the amount of time
that it takes to actually
attend a lot of these events.
Marketing.
Another thing that is
really not my favorite,
but I think a lot
of Indie developers
have a tendency
to make their game
their beautiful
precious baby, and then
they throw it over the
fence and they say,
am I a millionaire yet?
And that's just
not how it works.
It's a constant ongoing
effort to make people aware
of your game, to make people
care at all about your game.
Because guess what?
You're one of
thousands and thousands
of developers who are doing
exactly the same thing.
So this has to be a
constant ongoing effort
to rise above the noise.
Communication internal.
So I discovered very quickly
that I am terrible at art,
I am terrible at sound, I
am terrible at marketing.
So I brought in other
people to do these things.
And when you work
with other people,
you have to talk to those other
people, so that takes time.
Communication external.
There is a huge Indie
game dev community,
and if you're not taking
advantage of those folks
and really learning as
much as you can from them,
then you are doomed to fail.
I saw somebody recently
who has been at Indie
for about a year
and a half, and he
was doing this-- where he was
sitting in his house very, very
insulated and he had
created a game that
didn't look wildly interesting
and clearly had not gotten
input from almost anybody.
He was working on his own engine
and it looked like something we
could have built in Unity in
probably a couple of weeks.
So that, to me, was
clearly a failure
of just talking to other
Indies and learning
from them what they're
doing and their successes
and their failures.
QA and deployment.
Learning how to do QA and
learning how to deploy
was another huge hurdle for
me, and this just takes time.
I have released very,
very broken builds before,
and you don't want to do that.
So QA is a necessity.
So this chart, to me,
is really interesting,
because if you look at how
squashed that bottom bar has
gotten.
I spend less than half of my
time actually making the game.
And that's why I got into
this in the first place--
I just wanted to
make my own games.
So this is the reality
of the situation.
This is not a bad thing.
This is just how it has
to be to have really
any level of success.
So when I first-- I developed
The Counting Kingdom-- sorry,
I totally forgot to
introduce myself.
I made an educational
game for kids
called the Counting Kingdom.
Just released for iOS
recently, also on Steam.
When I first budgeted out how
long I thought that would take,
it was about six months.
It ended up taking about a year.
And if you take into
consideration this chart,
I was right on, because
given I was only
spending about half my
time working on the game,
it took twice as long as I
thought it was going to make.
So now, whenever I try to
estimate how long something
will take, I take my gut
check and then I double it,
and that's usually
pretty accurate.
OK.
So let's talk about
working with other folks.
So I discovered
very, very quickly,
I'm not particularly
good at art.
good at sound.
So I needed to bring
in other people
to compensate in these
areas that I was failing.
So I work with six people
very, very part time.
Luigi does art, Will does
PR, Sam does animation,
Jonas does sound effects.
Brendan does music and Emma
does community management.
And all of these people
were not just random people.
At no point did I
put out something
into the world saying, I'm
looking for a community
manager-- get in touch.
I would never do that.
That sounds like a lot of
work and just a terrible way
to actually find somebody.
So both Luigi and
Will are folks that I
met through the local
games community.
Luigi did the art for
Girls Like Robots,
and I basically stalked
him and tracked him down.
I was like, whoever did this,
I need them to make my game.
Fortunately, he
was a local guys,
and so I got to meet
him, talk to him
and discover that he was
a great for the team.
Both Sam and Jonas
were folks that were
recommended by people I trust.
Sam was an intern that I
brought into a local university
and Jonas was somebody that had
sent in a great portfolio piece
to another company.
They were not able to hire him,
but they basically put the word
out saying, this audio
guy looks amazing.
If anybody is looking
for an audio person,
you should snap him up.
So that's exactly what I did.
Then Brendan and Emma are people
that I previously worked with.
So the lesson to take away here
is, you have to be networking.
All of these folks were either
people that I knew directly
or people that knew
somebody that I knew.
As an Indie developer,
I have no time.
We've discussed this at length.
I literally have no time.
I am working more
than full time,
and so I cannot
micromanage somebody,
I cannot be on somebody's ass
to make sure they're getting
their work done.
And so, when I bring
somebody into the team,
it has to be somebody that
I trust to not only do work,
but to do amazing work and to be
able to do that independently.
So, for me, that means working
with folks that I already know,
that I already
trust, and with folks
that are highly recommended
to me by people that I trust.
And nobody else.
So if you're interested in
working with an Indie company,
don't sit around waiting for
them to put out job requests.
You need to be actively
trying to meet these folks.
Network.
So I want to talk a
little bit in detail
about what it means for
me to hire somebody.
This is how I do it--
it's not necessarily
how everybody does it.
When I bring somebody
in, I have them
sign a work for hire contract.
That basically just means
that they do work, I pay them,
and my company owns
the work that they do.
I then create
separate schedules,
and that's a tiny
one page document
that says, reference all that
other stuff in the contract.
Here is what needs to be
done by the contractor.
It needs to be
done by this date,
and here's what
they're getting paid.
So it's a very, very
simple document.
You can do the payment in
a couple of different ways.
So when I first worked with
Luigi, who's our artist,
we worked by bundles.
So I would say, I need
this list of art assets.
When do you think you
can get them to me,
and what would be
a reasonable price?
And we would negotiate both
of those last two things.
It was usually
three or four weeks,
and we would put that
up in the schedule
and then he would go
off and do that work.
Right now we've
switched to hourly,
just because it made sense
towards the end of the project,
because I would be like, oh,
I need this one particular
tiny little thing that I
completely forgot about,
and that didn't make
sense to do entire bundle
for like $20 worth of work.
So we switched to hourly.
It's also common to
do revenue share.
That could be the
entirety of the payment,
or that can be on top
of hourly payment.
Really depends on who
you're working with
and what make sense for you.
So this is just an
example-- oh my gosh, sorry.
This set up automatically.
Oops, there we go.
OK.
So this is an example of a
bundle that I did with Luigi.
You can see it just
lists in detail
all of the tiny little things
that I needed at that point.
So we ended up doing
four or five big bundles
and then swapped to hourly.
This was about halfway
through the project,
so you can see some things
are on the first strap,
like the world map.
Some things are getting
a lot more detailed,
like the level backgrounds.
But this is it.
A schedule is not
super complicated.
It's just a list of
what needs to be done,
when it needs to
be done by, and how
a person's getting paid for it.
The last thing I want to
talk about is the long tail.
We have this idea, I
think, in Indie development
that you're launch day
needs to be your big day.
Especially in mobile, you see
these graphs where it's like,
launch day the rest of the time.
Those graphs are super scary,
because it means if you're not
making a huge amount of
money on your launch day,
you have absolutely no income.
I think this is 100% the
wrong way to think about it.
When I launched The
Counting Kingdom on Steam,
it sold 35 copies on launch day.
35 copies.
I didn't think that was
possible for a Steam game
to sell that few
copies on launch day.
So that blew my mind, and
I was kind of like, OK,
I need to really rethink
what I'm doing here.
And since then, it's sold well.
It's sold steadily.
I've sold a lot more than
35 copies since then.
But I've had to really flip
my thinking about where
the money is being made.
So the point here is, this
is not a business plan.
Bullet point two has to be
a lot of different things
and it has to be over
a large span of time.
So for The Counting
Kingdom, we started
on Steam and the Humble Store.
We got into a Humble
Weekly bundle, which
was absolutely
phenomenal, and so far,
has been where the biggest chunk
of our money has come from.
Just launched on iOS, and I'm
looking towards the future.
There's a lot of different
things I could do.
I'm considering
porting to Android,
I'm considering trying
to get into schools.
I'm also talking
with other companies
about potentially licensing
The Counting Kingdom
for various opportunities.
This has to be ongoing.
There's the work
of making the game,
and then there's the work of
making money from the game,
and those are two
separate things.
That kind of sucks, but
it takes that much work
to actually make money from
something that you've already
poured your heart and soul into.
But that's just the reality of
the business of making games.
So this is frustrating,
but that's just
something that, again, is a
reality of being any developer.
It's something you
have to be aware of.
So that is all I have for you.
And Michael, come on down.
MICHAEL CARRIER: So my
name is Michael Carrier.
I'm the founder of
Zap Dot, Inc. I also
am one of the co-leaders
of Boston Indies
and the founder of the
Indie Game Collective.
It's a, as Rick mentioned,
a small group of studios
in the Cambridge area
that work together,
and we do a lot of things to try
to help ensure that everybody
is doing some awesome work
and that our products are
coming out really pretty.
Some of the projects
that I've worked
on-- so I started
off at Harmonics
and I worked on a
bunch of titles there.
From there, I did
an apprenticeship
with an MIT alum, [INAUDIBLE]
on the game Fallen Frontier
after he left Bungee.
I worked with the BBC and
a company out in west coast
called Pipeworks for
Dancing With The Stars
free to play online web game.
I worked with some local Indies,
Alchemy Labs on Jack Lumber,
and Dejobaan Studios in a
game called Drop That Beat
Like An Ugly Baby.
Another contract gig for
me was, the bottom left,
it's called Culture
Shock, which was
a game that taught
people who are
being deployed to the Middle
East cultural awareness.
This is really a cool game
for a group of neuroscientists
to try to prove
that games can help
people recover from concussions
effectively and efficiently.
And my two current
projects, [INAUDIBLE],
which is some contract
work and Pleasant Dreams,
which is a digital reboot of
a physical table top game.
Out of these-- one
second-- out of these,
the top four were
employment, and then
Dancing With The Stars,
Culture Shock, [INAUDIBLE]
and this neurologist
game were contract work.
So what I'd like to
do is give everybody
a little bit of context
for the information
that we'll be
talking about today.
There is a differentiation
between AAA and Indie.
I would prefer not to
use that terminology.
I want to talk about big
company versus small company.
Main reason being, with the
tools that are out there today,
AAA and Indie used to be
a description of quality
or subject matter, and I
really think those lines
are becoming blurred.
So talking about largest
to small company really
can encompass the
type of work that you
will be doing at those small
companies or big companies.
Either way, the
direction that you take
is going to be
really challenging
for one reason or another.
So if you work at
a larger company,
it's really important for
you to have a vast amount
of domain knowledge.
It's going to be challenging,
because you're not only
competing with local
talent, but global talent.
There are people from
all over the world that
want to work at these
companies, and these
are some of the
larger companies that
do hire and have hired
in the Boston area.
But if you know the story
behind some of these companies,
there is a lot of
overturn as well.
You end up having
people that come and go
and are laid off from project
to project just because
of the state of
the industry being
more of a project-based industry
that a long-term employment
type of industry.
So not only are you competing
with people all over the world,
but you're also competing
with really bright people who
have had years and
years of experience
at companies like these.
Smaller companies are
slightly different.
You have smaller teams,
you have smaller budgets,
and you have to
do more with less.
Typically, what you do is you
find people doing multiple jobs
to serve a lot of roles
and share the load
as much as they can.
With both of these, both
small and big companies,
the hours are long.
People don't always
respect you for your work,
and unfortunately, the
pay isn't always great.
Typically, you will make
a fraction of the salary
that you'd make with the same
skill set outside the industry.
But you know what?
That doesn't faze me.
I love the challenge.
Games are a really crazy field.
Video games haven't been around
in the public for 50 years,
and it's an incredible
medium already.
You want to think about
this-- the printing
press was released or invented
or became into mass use
in 1450.
It's 564 years later, and now
we have global information
networks and we're complaining
about these e ink displays,
at how bad they are or good they
are at displaying information
to us.
The medium constantly changes
on how that is distributed.
Just imagine where
games can go when
we are so young in this medium.
So I'm really here to talk to
you today about contracting.
It has served as my company's
primary method of revenue
over the past four years.
So there are some really
great benefits of it.
You get to work on
a ton of projects.
You meet a lot of
people, and you learn
a lot about different things.
If you're going to go back
and think about the projects
that I've worked
on, I got to work
on a free to play property
with a really big company who
had a huge marketing budget, and
it was really well-known name--
Dancing With The Stars.
A lot of people know that
TV show, or that property.
In terms of brand
recognition, it's great.
I got to work on a game
with some neurologists
and try to help
show that games have
positive impact in the world,
and that there are hopefully
ways, if the study does
come through positively,
that we can help people
recover from concussions more
effectively.
I got to work on a
game with the army.
Despite what you may think
about our involvement,
if we can help people learn how
to work with each other better,
I think that's a really
awesome thing to be a part of.
Now I'm getting to a point
where people are approaching
me to consult them for the
experience and knowledge
that I've gained over the course
of the past four to six years
that I've been in
the industry so far.
So one thing to keep in
mind, is that the great thing
about consulting and contracting
is that there is a ton of work
out there.
There are plenty of people
with ideas and money,
but they don't necessarily
have the skill or experience
to be able to bring
that to fruition.
Or their ideas were
a bit too large,
and they need some
more people to be
able to make those
ideas come to life.
Sometimes, they just decided
they want to bring someone in
to help them out
with the project
that they're working on.
I would also argue
that contracting,
once you get into
the rhythm of it,
is a very stable way to
make a long-term living
in this industry.
From what I've been
doing by contracting,
I'm expecting and
anticipating the project
to project work that the
industry typically creates.
With the network that I've
been able to create for myself,
I actually feel
very stable that I
will be able to find
something that someone will
be able to recommend me for
whenever a project ends if I
decide to keep contracting.
Ultimately, though, my goal is
not to do contracting forever.
The reason why I
created Zap Dot was
because I wanted to make
and release my own games.
When I started off, it
was important for me
to start generating some
revenue for the company
so that I could
hire people who were
worth the-- to bring people
because they were worth it.
I wanted to be able to pay them.
So after the past
four or five years,
I've been able to gain enough
capital for the company
where Zap Dot will
actually start
working on its own titles.
So I figured I would talk a
little bit about the contract
life cycle.
Very much like
Jenna said, events
are super, super important.
So you'll go to industry events
or you'll go to local meetups,
and there are a ton of
options, especially just
in the Boston area alone.
And you network and
you get to meet people.
The best advice that I can
offer you when you're networking
is, to not network for yourself,
but network for others.
Find ways to make introductions
between different people.
Find ways to get jobs
for other people.
The way that I've been able
to get such an awesome network
that I have right now is by
getting other people jobs.
In doing so, everybody
comes-- a lot of people
will come to me now
for advice or when
they have a project
that needs to be done.
So I become a holder
of information
in terms of the projects
that are available,
which, when my company wants
to pick one of those, I have,
essentially, the pick
of the litter for it.
Also, it's really good to
continually help people also
find stability in the industry.
To illustrate that,
the first job I got
was because I had a conversation
in a floral shop when
I was buying some flowers
for my girlfriend.
The second job was based
of a recommendation,
and the third job was also
based on a recommendation.
Another job was checking the
Boston Indies email list.
And the most recent job,
someone approached me
about doing the
work because they
had heard that I deliver
on time and my work
is pretty high quality.
So let's say you
do find someone.
You find someone and you
want to do work with them,
or they want work being done.
So what you do is, you do
this really weird dance
with the client and you
talk to them for a bit
about what kind of
work they want to do
and what kind of
project they want
to work on, why they want
to involve you in it,
and why you should be
involved in their project.
You either become really
scared about the expectations
that they have or the money that
they have to be able to spend,
or you'll fall in
love with them,
or there'll be some
in-between where
this is a good calculated
decision for you
or your company, and it
makes sense to do it.
From there, you take
those expectations
and you put them down to paper.
Contracts are really,
really important.
Never do any work or have
anybody do any work for you
unless you have them sign
some sort of contract.
Essentially, what these
contracts you do is,
they should manage expectations
for both you and the person
doing work.
What happens when something
goes wrong on either end?
Be very careful with things
like non-disclosure agreements
or non-competes.
I prefer to have all
non-competes written out
of contracts that I have signed.
I've heard of other people
asking for multiples
of their time because the
customer wanted the non-compete
to stick.
One other really important
thing to remember, especially
when you're doing
contracting is,
you have the opportunity to fire
a client as much as they have
the opportunity to fire you.
If people start
going off contract
and they start requesting
things that they didn't have
and they're not following the
rules that you've established
between your relationship,
then understand that you do
have the right to get out
of it if it goes sour.
So you've signed the contract.
Now you just need
to make the game.
Then after you make
the game, you get paid.
Jenna mentioned a bunch of
different types of payment.
You can do hourly
rates-- I've done that.
You can do milestone payments
where you agree, typically,
on two to four weeks of work.
You deliver that
work, and as long
as it is of acceptable
quality, the client
will accept it and then
you the amount of money
that you've worked on.
Or you can do a full
fee for a project.
I've done all three.
I would definitely caution
against doing full fee
for projects, just because--
especially if you're
a perfectionist or the
client starts trying
to add more things-- scope
can creep up over time
and you-- well, typically
for a full project fee,
unless you're very, very good
about your time management,
you'll end up doing more work
than what you charged for.
Sometimes you'll find
out that you need help.
Well, the cycle kind
of starts again.
You've gone to these
events that you people.
You do a little dance
with them to make sure
that they kind of fit
the situation for them.
If you find someone that you
want to be able to work with,
you write up a contract.
You set up expectations
for the work
that they will be coming
on to help you with.
And now, as an
employer of some sort,
you have to worry about
managing two people.
Not only are you
managing yourself
and the work that you are
delivering to a client,
you're making sure that
your contractor or employee
is doing the same thing,
that the client's happy.
Depending on how
many people you add,
it can take a lot of your time.
Over the past
couple of projects,
I have hired help or outsourced
some work for the projects
that I've done.
I've been able to
hire about five
to six people-- not all at once,
and not all for the same thing.
But some of the work that
I've had people come in for
has branched from a couple
hours to a monthly milestones
that I've paid
people to work on.
One really important thing
is that, with contracting,
especially if you're
running your own company,
there are a lot of other
responsibilities that you have.
There are taxes that you
need to worry about paying.
Stuff that normally would be
done if you were an employee
is not your responsibility.
There are definitely a
lot of different laws,
especially in Massachusetts,
about hiring people.
You need to be very
careful that you
are treating your
contractors like contractors
and not employees.
Otherwise, you should be
providing those employees
benefits.
And then that's
also the same thing,
to make sure that the
people that are hiring you
are treating you
like an employee
or expecting you to
act like an employee.
So make sure that you
pay attention to the work
that you're doing and
really round yourself out
on the rules and
regulations around work.
That's it.
So I wanted to open the
floor for Jenna and I
to let you jump in and
talk about any questions.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL CARRIER: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So do you have any advice
for marketing new games?
Because I think that's a thing
that a lot of [INAUDIBLE] how
do you promote your product
and where do you do it?
JENNA HOSTEIN: So
I've been doing
a lot of ongoing social media.
We have a Little World
Interactive Twitter account
and Facebook page.
A lot of it depends very much on
the type of game you're making.
The best approach to it is
a slow drip type of thing.
You don't get a week
away from launch
and go, OK, time to market this.
One thing that I've seen
work very successfully is,
we have somebody else
working in the IGC who's
creating a first
person dodge ball game,
and it's just wacky and fun.
So he's had huge success on
Reddit and with Live Streamer.
So he's an early
access, but he's already
been very, very
successful because he's
been able to tap into
those communities.
It's a lot of, what
companies can you tap into?
How do you reach those folks?
Then going to as many events
as you can afford slash
have time to.
In the past year, I've
exhibited at probably
a dozen different events-- some
really big, some really small.
But that has been crucial
to meeting players in person
and also to meeting
the journalists
that attend those
events as well.
So definitely
approach it as a very
ongoing got to put in a little
bit of effort every week
type thing.
MICHAEL CARRIER: Yeah.
Marketing should be a role
on itself on your project.
So very many people
will leave it
towards the end, like Jenna
mentioned in her talk,
or not do it all and just
kind of expect people
to flock to your game
after you've released it.
The other thing is, also as
Jenna mentioned in her talk,
is that marketing
is something that
needs to start before
your project has launched
and continue after
it has launched.
The more you can
kind of interweave it
into your game and the
entire development process,
the better it will be, the
more people will know about.
The objective is just to
get the most people know
about your title as possible.
JENNA HOSTEIN: And to add one
last thing to that-- the way
that I try to
approach social media
is to give people something
that they're excited to share.
So if you're just like, the
game's still on the store--
nobody's going to care about
that tweet or that Facebook
post.
But we do a lot of
cute little cartoons
of the characters from
the game, share a lot
of reviews, a lot
of testimonials
from parents and teachers.
The NASA online
presence is phenomenal.
If you want to see how
to do social media well,
follow the NASA Twitter feed.
It's seriously
astonishingly good.
They just did
something the other day
where they have a new upcoming
mission called Orion, I think.
And they did the ABCs of Orion.
So they did 26 tweets-- one for
each letter-- and each tweet
had this beautiful graphic
image of like, A for-- I
don't remember, I didn't
look it at all of them.
But it was very, very clever.
I ended up re-tweeting
the letters, S-P-A-C-E,
just because that
made me feel clever.
But they got me to re-tweet
five of their tweets.
That's a win for them.
So little things like that,
you have to think about,
what content can you
make that other people
are going to be really excited
to share with their networks?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the
street off of [INAUDIBLE]
and Massachusetts right now?
I know that there was some
stuff going to state legislature
about whether that's
actually enforceable.
MICHAEL CARRIER: Sure.
I've heard about that.
I don't think it's
completely unenforceable yet.
I don't think that
that's passed to make
non-competes unenforceable.
AUDIENCE: So there's debate?
MICHAEL CARRIER: Yeah.
JENNA HOSTEIN: Yeah, that's
a really good point, though.
You have to look very carefully
at any contracts that you sign.
A lot of companies will put
wording in there-- well,
studios will put
wording in there
that they own anything you
make regardless of whether you
make it at work or at home.
So especially if
you're someone who
likes working on side projects,
that can be very dangerous.
So just something
to be aware of.
MICHAEL CARRIER:
Especially ideas
that you've come up with during
working on their project.
There can be a large--
the more vague they are,
the more dangerous it is to you.
AUDIENCE: We have
another question.
AUDIENCE: Have either of you
worked with either state grants
or small business
grants-- organizations
that basically give money
for help for new companies?
What's the experience
like working some projects
if you have?
JENNA HOSTEIN: I have not yet.
That's something I'm actively
looking into for the next game.
The thing that's
holding me back is,
it looks like a lot of work in
a subject area I don't know.
I don't know how
to write a grant,
so that's something I would have
to learn for a shot at money.
So that's what's had we
not pursue that so far.
I'm going to be looking into
education-specific grants,
which I think I would just have
a better shot at, because it's
a more narrow field.
But-- not yet, but maybe.
MICHAEL CARRIER: The
neuroscientist game
that I worked on
was funded in part,
I think, by a grant
of the National
Institute of Health-- NIH.
AUDIENCE: I got you.
JENNA HOSTEIN:
Yeah, and I've heard
of a few Indies who are
working with institutions
who have gotten grant money.
But I don't know
of too many Indies
who have gotten grant money on
their own in the United States.
So other countries like
Canada and Australia--
though, I think, Australia--
maybe not anymore--
how government-funded
grants for the arts,
so they include games in that.
But we do not, unfortunately.
I would love some
government money.
AUDIENCE: How common is it
for studios to be acquired,
and is that something
they target?
MICHAEL CARRIER: So
I would say, it's
uncommon at a smaller level.
Definitely, the way that you're
going to make money as a studio
is not from an exit
strategy of being
purchased by a larger company.
It's more along the
lines of the revenue
that you'll be making
from either your contracts
or the profits from your game.
That being said, some
companies have been purchased.
I know one of the
other subcontractors
I worked with Dancing With The
Stars was purchased by a larger
company.
I know that Amazon has purchased
a few game companies when
they were launching the
Kindle to try to bring games
in for their platform.
So it's not impossible, but it's
definitely not an exit strategy
that most people
would start a studio
with the expectation of having.
JENNA HOSTEIN: Yeah,
and there's definitely
a group of Indie studios
who are generally
between 6 to 12 people and
they have an actual CEO
who can go out and raise money.
Those are Indie in
the sense that they're
small and self-owned and
independently publishing,
but it's kind of a
different class of Indie,
because they can be raising
potentially millions of dollars
to fund their games.
So those are the types
of companies that would
be most likely to be purchased.
Little Worlds Interactive
is just me and my games,
and so if somebody were
to purchase my company,
they would just be
hiring me, basically,
and like, purchasing my games.
So that's probably not something
that's going to happen,
though it's not
unheard of entirely.
MICHAEL CARRIER: And I
guess a tangential approach
that you could have-- that
is, actually taking your games
and licensing them out
for other properties.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How long were
you guys in the industry
before starting to
do your own thing?
JENNA HOSTEIN: So I
was in the industry
for-- it depends
on what you count.
So, grad school for two years
and working for four years,
and then I've been
an Indie for two.
MICHAEL CARRIER: I
worked at Harmonics
for just under two years before
I started doing consulting.
The Culture Shock game was
my first project out of it.
JENNA HOSTEIN: A lot of
people-- just to add onto that
and then look at you up
there-- a lot of people
go straight from
undergrad to Indie,
and that's a totally
valid approach.
But there is also so much
to be learned in a studio.
Even if that is not
your ideal environment--
it certainly wasn't for
me-- but I regularly
use things that I learned in
my time working at a studio.
So I wouldn't necessarily
recommend just
going directly Indie
straight from undergrad.
MICHAEL CARRIER: And this
is part of a different talk,
but-- I didn't go into that.
But it's a bad idea,
just because there
are a lot of mistakes that
you'll make on your own
that you could have learned
from a larger company who's
already made those mistakes
and can teach you better ways.
Not that they'll have
all the right answers,
but-- and it's not to say
that you won't be successful
if you were to do it
right out of school.
It's just much harder to hit.
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering, Jenna--
what did you work on
before you became an Indie?
What were you doing,
or what was grad school
and then after that experience?
JENNA HOSTEIN: So
after undergrad,
I worked at a local startup
called Hangout Industries
and we were making one of the
original 3D virtual worlds.
So it was meant to be a social
chill place for teen girls.
It crashed and burned hard.
Most of the lessons I
learned at that company
were how not to do the
things we were trying to do,
which is valuable.
Which is a very valuable lesson.
So then I went to
Indiana University
and got my master's
degree in game design,
and then came back here and
worked at Stomp Games, which
was formerly Tencent Boston.
We did Robot Rising-- and
that was a diablo-esque game
with robots on Facebook.
So I've kind of bounced
all over the place.
I've made mobile titles,
I've made Facebook titles.
I had an internship at Turbines
where I've worked on MMOs.
And like I was saying before,
that experience really
has just given me a breadth
of knowledge that I've
been able to apply to Indies.
AUDIENCE: So a number
of the other people
we brought into class
were talking a little bit
about the internships
that they had
[INAUDIBLE] larger companies.
Can you talk a little
bit about-- so you
mentioned you used an intern
for your process, Jenna.
I forget if you
mentioned [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL CARRIER: I have
not used interns yet,
but it's something that
I am very excited about.
AUDIENCE: So can you
talk a little bit
about how it works
for your small studio
and what the
experiences might be
for being an intern
at one of you studios
compared to a larger studio?
JENNA HOSTEIN: Sure.
So the intern that I
worked with was Sam.
He was an animator, and he went
to school at a local animation
school, I don't remember
what it was called--
and I knew one of
the teachers there.
As part of their
graduate requirements--
I think they called
it a co-op-- they just
needed to put in a
certain number of hours
with a local studio.
The expectation was
that it was unpaid,
because they were basically
getting course credit for it.
So for me, it was a
risk-free situation.
Like, basically, I could get
somebody to do art for me
for free, but they were getting
something out of it too,
so I didn't have to
feel too horribly
guilty about not paying them.
And it worked out phenomenally.
So one of the big
differences with working
with an Indie versus
a large studio
is that, I basically
said to him,
I need animation in my game.
If you could do that,
please, that would be great.
So he did all of the animation
in The Counting Kingdom,
first as an internship, and
then as a paid contractor
down the road.
So he got a massive
amount of responsibility.
The only door art direction
I gave him was, like,
make it cute, but also scary a
little bit, but not too scary.
So he had just a huge
amount of creative control.
The downside to that was,
we all worked remotely,
and so I saw him maybe
once every couple of weeks.
But we stayed in
touch to make sure
that he knew what was
going on, I was going on.
So at a larger
studio, he would have
more face-to-face
experience, but be
working on a much
smaller slice of the pie.
Given that Indie
budgets are zero,
basically, I would not be able
to bring in a paid internship
intern.
As much as I would like to,
it's just not a reality.
If I'm paying
somebody money, I have
to know that they are
going to be able to produce
incredibly high quality work.
So unless you're
very, very cheap
and you already have an
astonishingly good portfolio,
it's not something I can afford.
MICHAEL CARRIER: I would
say one of the major reasons
why we haven't brought
in-- why Zap Dot hasn't
brought in any interns right
now is for the same reason.
I would want to try
to pay something,
and I've not been able
to be in a position
where I could bring
someone in to give them
a specific set of tasks
to be able to work,
or to have a project that
is ready to do research
and development.
I think one thing that
is great for interns
that I'm very interested
in is actually
having them do prototypes to
test ideas that the company has
for future plans and to
get a good feel for that.
Because I think
it could encompass
lot of things that are great
for interns-- being able to have
a project, being able
to deliver on things,
and then also being
able to have something
that may have some
progress going forward
in a project that is released.
JENNA HOSTEIN: That
being said, a lot
of times, we think about
internships as kind of an all
or nothing type thing.
But a lot of us
could use somebody
a couple of hours a week to help
out with things here or there.
So if you genuinely are looking
for the experience-- and again,
I hate not paying people--
but if you do just
want some experience
working with an Indie studio
and you're willing to give just
a couple hours a week, come
to Boston Indies.
Comes to Boston Unity Group
where we're all there.
Come talk about the projects
you're interested in
and where you might be
interested in helping.
MICHAEL CARRIER: And those
things can turn into paid work
as well, as Jenna's intern did.
PROFESSOR: Any last questions?
Three or four.
AUDIENCE: So both of you
are located at the IGC,
but the impression I'm getting
is that not all the people
you work with are physically
in the IGC [INAUDIBLE].
Can we talk about
how you balance that?
And I guess [INAUDIBLE]
the whole communications
part of it, but what does that
work flow look like with some
of your people right
next to you and some
of those people on Skype?
JENNA HOSTEIN: Go ahead.
MICHAEL CARRIER: Want
me to go for that one?
JENNA HOSTEIN: Go ahead.
MICHAEL CARRIER:
Many of the projects
that I've done have
been remote work.
When I was doing
Dancing With The Stars,
that was a bunch of people.
So New Hampshire,
Oregon and Florida.
Jack Lumber was
Manitoba, Canada.
Then my apartment,
and then Alex's
apartment as well, before
we had the opportunity
to work together.
Typically what you need when
you're working remotely is,
you need a couple of things that
are set in stone, essentially.
You need a schedule, you need
deadlines that people actually
make, and you need to make sure
that you have the people that
are working on those projects
be very, very good at time
management in the sense that
they know they have work to do.
They don't necessarily need to
have co-workers working around
them.
So what you find is, you find
a lot of tools being reused.
So Google Docs for
shared collaboration,
Trello for task management,
and then Skype for group chats,
I think.
Or Google-- we've done
Google Hangouts as well
for different projects.
But essentially,
having something
that allows the team to
communicate with each other
and knowing what
the expectations
are throughout the project.
Especially when the
contracting work is remote.
Like, I'm going to do the work
because I want to get paid.
I guess it's just
a matter of making
sure you have really good work
ethic and a schedule that you
stick to or update
as things change.
JENNA HOSTEIN:
Yeah, it definitely
varies from person to person.
But having the right tools
to make your life easier
is crucial.
So I'm on Skype all the time,
and I also use BitTorrent Sync,
I think is what it's
called-- where basically, I
have a shared folder
with my contractors.
Any time they update a
file on their computer,
it'll be updated on my computer.
So it's just a
very, very easy way
make sure we have the most
recently updated files,
and don't have to
keep renaming them,
like, final-- final two--
final, really final.
It just keeps all
nice and clear.
So having the right tools--
just as a few examples,
because that'll
probably be easier
talk about with Luigi, who
is the artist-- we would
sit down and talk either
in person or on Skype
before every new big major task.
That made sure that we were
both on the right page.
We both had a similar
thing in our heads,
and any design requirements,
I was able to specify.
He was able to ask questions
about some of the things
I would forget about.
So making sure you have those
regular face-to-face check-ins
every time you're starting
something new is crucial.
Emma, who is my social media
guru, works four hours a week
and she basically keeps our
Twitter and Facebook pages
updated.
We check in regularly, if
there are any sort of campaigns
that I want to kick off.
But part of the reason
I brought her on board
is because every time I
would sit down with a Twitter
account, I'd be like, I have no
idea what I'm supposed to say.
Like, still working on the game.
And so her job is to come
up with creative ways
to be like, just a reminder,
the game is still out there
and you should purchase it!
In a way, it sounds
like something people
should be excited about.
So her job really is to
work a little bit more
independently and come up
with that stuff on her own,
but then there are some
times, like, I totally
want to steal this
NASA ABCs thing--
and so I'm going to
talk to her about it
and plan that out and
put that together.
So she does a lot
of independent work,
but then any major projects,
we check in for that.
MICHAEL CARRIER: Not
steal-- appropriate.
JENNA HOSTEIN: Borrow.
Borrow.
PROFESSOR: Thank you
so much for your time.
JENNA HOSTEIN: All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: You can go ahead and
keep the microphone on, just
in case.
So we've got a
five minute break.
Come back down here and sign
in if you haven't signed in
for class yet.
They're available to play
your games if you are
ready for that sort of thing.
So if you are, find them,
bring them to your computer,
and have them play.
MICHAEL CARRIER: We'll leave
a bunch of our business cards
up here.
If you want to send a
portfolio, a resume,
just get some feedback,
please feel free.
I'll answer any email
that comes my way.
PROFESSOR: And I'm going
to email this out to them,
I haven't done it
yet, but there's
a party coming up, right?
MICHAEL CARRIER: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Can you mention that?
MICHAEL CARRIER: Yeah.
The Indie Game
Collective-- there's
actually two parties coming up.
PROFESSOR: Mention both.
MICHAEL CARRIER: The
Indie Game Collective
is having a party at the
Aeronaut Brewery in Somerville.
It's in between
Porter and Union.
It is on December 11, starts
at 5:30, goes until 11:30.
It's Thursday, so
you'll probably
have to leave a little
early so you can
get to class early on Friday.
But the-- ah, no one
laughed, even politely.
AUDIENCE: I think that's
after the last day of class.
MICHAEL CARRIER: Oh, OK.
Cool.
So the collective is
doing a bunch of art
and interactive installations.
It's games that are
not our own games,
but they're just
fun things that we
wanted to make for
the sake of art,
not necessarily making money.
Bit Fest Boston will also have
20 old school arcade cabinets
there.
We will have a funk
band and a food truck
that has gluten-free, vegan, and
non-alcoholic options as well.
On the Monday following, which
I think is December 15th,
Boston Indies is having
their holiday festivus
where people will be
just playing games.
It'll be some
local Indies who'll
be demoing some games
that they've made,
but we'll also just be
playing really fun games
like JS Joust or Hokra.
Jenna did an Artemis
game last year.
So who knows what type of
table top or digital games
will be there?
But it'll be a lot of fun too.
And that's going to be-- that
is in the new Bocoup office.
Go to bostonindies.com
and join the community
in terms of finding out
more information about that.
I'll be sending it out shortly.
PROFESSOR: Thanks.
So take five minutes.
2:05, 2:10 we're going
to take that thing away.
All right?
[CHATTER]